oh i've got the stars of top gear on the
show tonight i'm running a bit late but
i've put my foot down
[Applause]
i think i need a drink watch out
probably shouldn't drink and drive here
you take it there
[Applause]
oh
that's a couch oh how lovely
yeah i have to say normally normally in
a kind of bland way when everyone sits
down i just go you all look great but i
can't really do that because the head
honcho of the fashion police
is on the couch how are we doing joan
okay
uh
we shouldn't even talk you look fine
because black makes everybody look thin
except aretha franklin but you look good
you know you either have it you don't
you know what i'm saying
fashion is like herpes either have it or
you know
can you see my nipples
i don't want to good
it's undressed
[Applause]
james may though down the end there oh
but you spent a lot of money on clothes
don't you
uh yeah occasionally
but but i have this fantastic ability to
make either expensive clothes or very
cheap very tatty clothes look equally
crap
and
it's it's a gift
you actually do look particularly
tonight
even by his own low standards
i don't think you look so bad thank you
very much yeah but you're in brokeback
mountain so
in case this gets awkward later i think
i should bring this up now yes that uh
john bishop you do have a connection to
tom cruise uh
yes yes yes uh yeah we do have a
connection because we were both i was on
uh top gear
shortly after tom was on top gear this
is the star in a reasonably nice car the
star in the reasonably priced car and
you did very well top i did all right
yeah yeah you top of the leaderboard how
did you do john
here's the leaderboard
john bishop yeah beat you two seconds
[Applause]
happened was me there was tom cruise he
was cameron diaz and then and then
ripper clinch his fourth wasn't he
rupert grint yes yes i'm a wizard i even
beat a wizard
tell me that you didn't just beat us you
crushed us that's 142.8 that's
that's a good uh full second and a half
almost i know and the thing is like you
can drive cars and you're interested
i've got zero interest in cars
you chose the wrong profession
tell me about it i came away from that
thing and i've i should be an f1 because
all it was to me though was somebody
give me a car yeah and said it doesn't
matter if you crash it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hosting top gear is like your dream job
yeah it's kind of like this it's a lot
bigger than i thought it was you know
when i when i first did the show it was
fun and then
now being a part of it i mean it is a
just a international juggernaut of a
show but it showed in 170 territories or
countries or something yeah so it
premieres this sunday and by wednesday
it'll be in 83 countries on six
continents already by wednesday
wow that's it's just huge and like how
did this happen did you call them did
they call you did you bump into someone
and lift how does it happen
well i did it the first time to promote
episodes and did the around the track in
the car and that went pretty good well
you were the fastest ever aren't you are
you still the bosses
yeah no
and then they did this thing called top
gear the races which was
kind of like the greatest hits of top
gear and i kind of introduced the clips
shot these little video wrap arounds and
that went good and then chris was
already on board at that point and they
approached me and asked if i would
like to be a part of it and i wasn't
doing anything else
and it's been a lot of fun chris and i
get along good it's really fun yeah and
you are a proper petrolhead i mean you
do love cars and engines and all that
stuff yeah you know it's funny like i
i'm one of those people i subscribe to
like about 15 different car magazines
you go to my house on the coffee table
just stacked up with forever i've been
doing that and someone just said to me
that day finally it's paying off
you knew you were preparing for this job
your whole life
and the first episode part of it is a
kind of britain versus america challenge
yes that's right yeah so what what's the
challenge okay so do you know the
reliant robin remember that oh yeah
there they are yeah well these are
reliant rialto's the upgraded one which
i don't know what they change is still a
not a very nice car i've never heard of
a realtor anyone the reliant robin
you've heard of yeah robert was made
famous by only fools and horses yeah he
wasn't it yeah he did a little van
didn't he yeah no we had one one of
those didn't he but it was a van version
what do they have oh they've got an open
route oh they've cut the roofs off
because it was going to be raining so
they figured it better to have no roof
yes
it's great
so we have to drive from london to
blackpool in those
nice and my mine broke down about ten
times
the first one and i think chris had it
fixed because it's usa versus the uk and
we're in english cars his is painted
like the union jack mine stars and
stripes and mine breaks down repeatedly
his ran like a clock
go figure
had matt blank ever been to blackpool
before no he hadn't
will matlock be returning
he might
no it was you know we actually had a
really good time and then you went back
to uh my neck of the woods you were in
southern ireland west cork and uh kerry
the ring of kerry yeah dingle and uh
killarney and all that we did a thing
with uh rolls-royce over there that was
really fun wow and now it was this woman
was she just taking a picture and you
literally drove by
she was with their girlfriend and they
were on their way to the her hen do you
call it like yeah that's right party we
call it the states and we were driving
up the road it was me and the new
rolls-royce uh dawn the convertible and
chris evans was in his rolls-royce
corniche from 76 and there was a
comparison old and new and we'd kind of
had a red light and i think it was in
dingle
and they walk in there and they come
over hey and they just took a selfie
she put it on twitter or something
social media or whatever it was you look
genuinely happy
she had a very short skirt
[Applause]
you look suspiciously happy
more of a belt
it was a hindu
but jeremy okay i understand how
sometimes controversy can stumble into
your life but you do seem to go looking
for it i don't oh come on you're
tweeting the car registrations of people
who annoy you on the road
i just think that's funny because they
think they've got away with it and you
just go you haven't
i think i've only got 86 followers so
that doesn't really help but it's it's
it's nice from my point of view i just
think well that's good because it's paid
them back
and james you seem so nice i am does do
you
do you hate anything uh yeah i have
irrational hatreds like wiring i hate
wires like on computers under the desk
okay or behind the television okay but
there's a lot of wires ocd the other
thing i hate is
i accept that this is irrational but
it's those wouldn't
those wooden sticks you get especially
in america for stirring a coffee
because all the misery of humanity is in
that piece of wood because you because
the coffee has become such an elaborate
construct you have a double chocolate
talk a lot with an extra shot and a dash
of chocolate and a cardboard thing and a
warning about the heat and the top with
a hole that you're pushing it and then
they say would you like this piece of
splintery wood
and it does and it doesn't stir it up
because it's really thin and it goes
round and round and nothing happens and
everybody goes hell yeah and then puts
it in that bid
why
i hate it
so i'll give you an idea of how much ocd
james has got
okay this is a watch it's got the little
pointer thing that has to go by the 12
yes so if i talk to james and it's there
everything's right if i do that it
drives him yeah because you're not
actually timing anything so if you don't
like it
you can't just leave it
because it's the funniest thing in the
world when he's talking on top here i'll
just sit and go
and it shuts him up because it's not
straight
does anything kind of grind your gears
nothing i'm always so calm and i have so
together at all times are you really yes
i believe you i hate nothing
everything's so beautiful oh
[Applause]
what a wonderful world
well listen we thought we thought we
might just ask the audience if there's
anything that you know annoyed them
slightly
dear god
it was a tsunami of hatred
so let's go and meet some of the the
people in the audience if you agree or
do feel free to chip in where's er is it
nathan where's nathan nathan oh right up
there okay dear god all right stand up
nathan do where are you excuse my excuse
i'm sorry so what what annoys you nathan
people with really wet limp handshakes
yes
yes see jake hates that we found
something so jake's nodding he doesn't
no no no no everything's so beautiful
we'll get you where's siobhan gallagher
siobhan gallagher oh there's siobhan she
won excuse my excuse i stand up to uh
what annoys you
men with cats
[Music]
[Applause]
oh there's julie stand up too now what
annoys you um children that stare yes
yes
the devil
[Music]
when you're on an aeroplane
is there a terrorist on board
i'm willing to help out
brilliant i'm going to write a column
about that oh
where's uh deborah miranda hello deborah
stand up dude hi hi and uh what do you
hate
jeremy clarkson
[Applause]
actually no
actually no i'm going to put my foot do
you know i didn't say anything
unpleasant about mexicans
no i was sitting near a man who said
something unpleasant but that was enough
for me to spark few it wasn't even him
the irritating little brummy midges on
the other hand
got cleaned away with it no i would
apologize on his behalf we actually went
to the mexican embassy to apologize on
his behalf
and we got absolutely
he said paralytic to the mexicans
bridges have been built yes all right
well done thank you very much everyone
it was all the haters very good but top
gear yeah you properly wanted that job
that that that was a one job because for
me being a cricketer that was it that's
all i ever wanted to do and i stumbled
into telly and i've had some good jobs
um done some bad ones as well and
when top gear came up the first time
around after almond clarkson and mayor i
said to me agent i i'd love a crack at
that and he was saying no yeah not yet
and then a few years later i just come
off filming a legal run and he said
you'll never guess you've got a screen
test for top gear and then i got really
competitive with it like a sportsman was
like i want to get this i want to do
this so i went to the screen test
and winged it and managed to get the job
and now it's great i love cars i love
driving around um paddy's great and
chris harris
but some of the things you do
are i mean you know because i get it you
like cars but bungee jumping in a car i
mean even you must have thought yeah i
realized why they wanted me then um
and i'm actually dispensable do you sign
by the way do you sign a bit of paper
saying
if i die don't worry about it you've got
to sign waivers and insurance and things
but with some of the stuff i've done
before i've got this reputation of being
a bit of a dirt devil and no fear it is
not the case
i'm bricking it in that car i'm over a
dam in switzerland and it was a car
bungee and a metro and i had to pull the
ambrick to go
and the one thing about bungee jumping
is if it's on your legs you know you're
attached but i'm in a car and i'm going
down just thinking please please be
attached oh because you don't know the
car doesn't feel anything can you get a
seatbelt on but that's not gonna help is
it when you're at the ground
airbag yeah i'm fine
it's an old metronome
where is the hamster where is little mr
richard hammond you know honestly he's
in mexico
he's there as a punishment though he's
making amends no he's um deborah storm
the stage kill him
i guess you're back differently you'll
be in america he's always an american
he's one of those
they're people to be americans and he's
one of those people i'm always in
america too yes yes
because he wants he says
he goes i'll take a bud
like you do oh that's good please may i
have yeah
i'll take a bird no you won't richard
please may i have to
does that bbc can i get a coffee and can
i get one of those sticks as well
oh shut up about the sticks all right
now listen we must mention top gear
because it is i think is it the most
successful television program in the
world it is now it's seen by 350 million
people in 170 countries and this year
you're celebrating the 10th anniversary
congratulations
[Applause]
i'm only celebrating my nine and a half
anniversary he was lost for the first
series we told him what the studio was
he has no sense of direction james i
just thought it was a really long way
away he got lost at what he claims is
the second albert hall we've tried to
explain to him there is only one but he
maintains there are two there you go
still to this day says there were two
albert halls and he got lost at it so we
had to get another man to stand into it
have you done the top gear no i haven't
no i haven't you why haven't you done it
because i'd be useless you would not be
the slowest just who would like would
you like to see graham dirt yeah
unfortunately that's your january book
sir
no i always look at it thinking could i
do that could i cause you but can't you
be killed doing no
well yes yes
i was scared coming on this show you
could be killed on this show
you die in an anecdote which is the most
important thing don't you think to die
i remember once being in a russian-built
plane that had been in the angolan air
force and was being is used in cuba and
it was upside down plummeting towards
the earth and i actually remember
thinking well at least the kids have got
a great anecdote you know how did your
dad die
pretty good actually and it was very
funny thought it'd be okay so die in a
reasonably priced car would be all right
i think yes and i actually would say if
anyone's speaking at the funeral they
could just show the footage
yes i just want to refer back to a
television appearance that you
bonneville made a couple of weeks ago uh
he was on a program called top gear it's
very oh i love that
he was on top gear driving that's the
greatest show now from top gear no we
don't have a clip but we do have a
bizarre his appearance caused quite the
reaction
uh here he is on top of you now a lot of
people were focused on the jumper
why are you wearing lipstick on top here
[Applause]
trust me you're wearing lipstick you're
wearing it
there you go
i am not wearing lipstick i have never
warmed this thing in my life it looks
what it does look like that was a very
cold day
well i'm intrigued i i'm here to say
that i was not wearing lipstick
it was
cold because they on top of you they say
bring two sets of clothes you're gonna
be boiling hot in the car
and you're gonna be freezing cold in the
studio and i thought boiling hot in the
car it's a cold day in wherever we are
february it's not gonna be like that at
all i was roasting because you were
exerting so much so adrenaline and a
sweat because you're in a well
well just right now
your lips are turning a different color
[Music]
and then you're in the studio this
aircraft hangar where apparently last
summer it's either incredibly hot or you
know it's freezing at this time of year
and last year when patrick stewart was
on my lips aren't going red aren't they
yes really
i do
they just go red on tv
[Music]
it's an odd look for a man but you carry
it off
so
[Laughter]
apparently about four or five people
stopped healing uh about four or five
people fainted while patrick stewart was
doing his thing because it was so hot
and i was thought it's gonna be very
chilly sort of my favorite woolly jumper
but not my red lippy which i left
[Laughter]
he just said my lips my favorite woolly
jumper come on
how many women here are going to faint
just hearing him say my favorite word
all right how many men are going to
favor
my favorite jumper in my lippy
[Music]
lippy what's that mean in america i
don't know
now if you want to hear more traffic
based ranting of that quality you could
do worse than buy the dvd
the worst car in the history of the
world oh no just in the world i didn't
say ever i thought maybe it said ever
because you guys like nice cars
why don't we just say that now and then
go back to joan no no
well i'd rather listen to joan than
drone on about cars frankly she's much
more interesting we need to sell it a
bit well we have done now okay yeah buy
that now joe tell me more
maybe you would agree why not i said
when i go a bit further you please do
buy you don't have to watch it all we're
bothered about is that you buy it yeah
but you went to trouble to make it you
did actually go around and we were
contractually obliged to actually put
something on the disc in the box you can
tell that
have you actually seen the photographs
of us on the front cover
in fairness i don't think you knew that
picture was being taken no it's it looks
like
look at him look at this he thinks it's
lauren mccall
looks like our carers instead they just
take the jackets off and they got the
picture now pop them back on again they
wouldn't allow me out in public looking
like that
so was it hard to pick the worst car in
the world ever not really no why
because it was the worst car in the
world ever actually if you sit down and
think about i mean i won't say what it
is because obviously we want people to
buy that you're not spoiled but no we
rattled through about six or seven
choices and they went it is
this car because the expectation of it
was very good but it was actually awful
so you bought it and thought well i'm
really doing quite well you look at
yourself in shock windows dear i'd look
a bit of a plonker and then it was awful
so we said it was is it an initial or a
name it's a name but you would have to
be
is it did you know it as soon as you saw
it
as soon as we mentioned it we said yes
but you would have to be moronic to buy
one really give us a hint no john don't
i just say spoil it
i am that
i i have owned the worst car in the
world that have but i liked it
[Applause]
are you making that up no seriously i
only got rid of it because my dog
outgrew it
you had that car that we think is the
worst genuine is my favorite car ever
well i said i meant magnificent
no did you choose it on purpose because
you knew that i had
i didn't know you actually had i thought
you had a porsche no i did have one of
those i didn't like that no it's
horrible no and then i had this and i
loved it i would still like check it out
say it if you say you love it i don't
know because
it spoils this at the end of the video
i'm very caring like that oh i'll tell
you after yeah i'm going to have to go
buy that dvd
never watch it here's ears
[Music]
you